now to an update on the death of a 29
year old black man in Memphis his name
was Tyree Nichols his family says body
cam video of a confrontation with police
officers shows that the officers beat
him for three minutes Nichols was
arrested earlier this month after a
traffic stop and this photo was taken in
the hospital afterward he died just days
later the Memphis Police Department says
it fired five officers involved in the
arrest for using excessive force and
failing to render Aid now all five of
the officers are black lease Preston is
in Memphis where she spoke with the
Nichols family
all I heard my son say was what did I do
and I just lost it from there Tyree
Nichols mother Ravon Wells told us she
could only watch some of the body camera
video allegedly showing police beating
her son I am so numb and I'm just trying
to wrap my head around all of this his
family says Nichols was restrained
beaten tased and pepper sprayed by
several Memphis police officers while
other officers stood by and did nothing
to help I saw police brutality at its
finest I saw
a helpless young black man being beat by
several officers Memphis Police pulled
Tyree Nichols over on January 7th for
reckless driving they said when they
approached him there was a confrontation
and he ran away police said when they
caught up to him and tried to arrest him
there was a second confrontation they
said Nichols complained of shortness of
breath and was taken to the hospital
that's where his father took this photo
it shows Nichols bloodied and bruised he
died days later after seeing the body
camera video attorneys for the Nichols
family compared it to the 1991 beating
of Rodney King by Los Angeles police he
was defenseless
the entire time
he was
a human pinata for those police officers
it was an unadulterated
unabashed non-stop beating of this young
boy for three minutes
the Nichols family is calling on the
officers involved to face charges for
them to beat my child the way they did I
mean where's the humanity you just beat
him like a dog in the street
that's heartbreaking very heartbreaking
now the Department of Justice has
launched a civil rights investigation
the district attorney says video will be
released to the public in the next two
weeks once a federal and state
investigations are concluded Tony
I'm sure that video is going to be very
tough to watch the anguish there of
tyree's mother Elise thank you very much
for that report just a shot Tony of that
picture of him in the hospital bed you
know
yeah I don't know how you don't look at
that and think excessive for us right
you know the case is still of course
under investigation but just that one
shot alone is so disturbing one man
against all those offices mother said it
best where's the humanity where's the
humanity